welcome to the global roundtable this
series focuses on the future of economic
competition I'm Parag Khanna joined by a
distinguished panel including the Mesa
moyo Daniel Altman and uninsured Harless
today's topic is the new maritime Silk
Road despite the financial crisis we
have emerging market regions trading
ever more with each other and even
becoming engines a global economic
growth into the future we have maps that
show that the resource-rich persian gulf
countries are increasingly selling their
oil not to the west but across the
Indian Ocean to the east hence this new
maritime Silk Road what does it mean
though can it really be the core driver
of the global economy moving forward
well fundamentally we shouldn't be
surprised at that I mean we these are
the economies backed up by these large
populations of people who are trying to
improve the economic living standards
it's not just a middle eastern China I
mean the fact that China has about seven
percent arable land means that she's
always going to be looking for places
that have more arable land to financial
to provide food stuffs the fact that
Africa is the largest place with
untilled arable land left on earth means
is a natural symbiosis a natural
relationship actually emerged there
these are depleting resources so the
question is how much of this can
continue over the long term look there's
no doubt that countries like China and
even countries like Saudi Arabia need
lots of resources to feed their people
and feed their factories but we're at
risk of a new kind of colonialism
developing here which isn't at the end
of the barrel of a gun but rather at the
end of a billion dollar check I think
that it's going to cause instability I
think in the long term it creates more
risks than it gets rid of for these
countries even though they're doing
trade it's the leaders who are making
the deals not the people so you're
saying comparative advantage is what is
connoted by this term New Silk Road yet
at the same time it's actually very
mercantile in nature I think there's
some really course of relationships that
are developing and you only have to look
at China's influence over the foreign
policy of some of the country's it does
business with to see a new set of client
States developing I'd produce lightly
different context which is I think two
dumb beasts s point earlier this is
about risk the restoration of normalcy
in a way these are countries having
relationships with each other that are
not mediated by the West and it's going
to continue and I think this is one of
the questions where the West is to think
about how can it still be relevant at 10
years ago 20 years ago maybe still today
of a Korean company one
to buy a venezuelan company it would
probably still use New York investment
bankers we're probably moving into a
world where they'll use Korean or
Venezuelan investment bankers and with
shipping and with any other thing is the
West even going to be in the middle of
all these transactions among countries
that are outside the way in this 21st
century Silk Road actually you have
Latin America and Africa as participants
and growing share in fact of trade and
exports more than in any other period of
history so in that sense it's an
unmitigated good thing isn't it oh I
think it's a missed trick by what
developed countries I mean if you think
about the last 50 years Africa's
proximity and historical context has
absolutely been with Europe and the
United States but their approach I mean
dealing with the economic challenges of
Africa's face in particular has been one
of handing out aid not developing
economies not building a long-term
relationship around agriculture and so
on so they're going to pay for that now
it's not just Africa the fact that
Brazil and Chile now have China as the
largest trading partner means the Monroe
Doctrine is certainly something of the
past Daniel how do we make the countries
that are on the receiving end of this
check that may be masking a gun how do
you make them equal participants it
really has to come from inside these
countries if they're more democratic and
more meritocratic will be able to have a
better say in their economic futures but
that growth which is creating the
south-south trade is really a salubrious
thing for the west as well because it's
creating more economic power in these
parts of the world that can be consumer
markets for the United States and Europe
in the future these marriages of
convenience are really going to continue
into the foreseeable future you
mentioned China has an arable land
shortage while Africa has a huge amount
of agricultural productive potential
growing consumer markets and which
require energy in Asia and of course
energy supply in the Middle East raw
materials from Latin America going to
the other markets so but what where
might this breakdown is one question
that I think we need to ask resource
constraints absolutely I mean the fact
that we've got nine billion people
planned for 2050 means that arable land
issues around water issues around energy
issues around minerals are absolutely
going to be front and center and this is
where again I think the West unite led
by the United States really has an
important role in keeping the innovation
and I'm cutting edge and fresh because
we will need to figure out a solution to
to provide for all this we have many
silk road's in the future but that
doesn't mean that we are not all on the
same planet and have to face resource
constraints this is really an intimate
issue for the future of global economy
and global competition thanks for
joining us more on that and other topics
at big thing calm